hey this is dave from voit smith
innovation and today we're gonna be
doing a video on the steps that we
recommend and the steps that we also
personally take for cleaning out our
liquid di series
these would be the steps that we
recommend obviously when we summarize
the units for storage over the summer
until next deicing season as we know
salt brine in itself especially the
additives that we run can be very
corrosive now it's really not an issue
with the the components of the system
itself I mean everything that we run is
either poly or stainless but there are
some sensitive electronics on the unit
and some parts of the engine that we
want to address before we let them sit
all summer the main point of concern
would be the electronics including the
servo valve and what can actually happen
is one these units sit the water
evaporates out and leaves the salt
behind and salt water is actually a very
interesting mixture because the salt can
actually creep out of places that the
water can't so it's very important that
we flushed all the salt water out of the
system and just make sure that the pump
electronics the valves everything are
clear of the salt so it doesn't sit in
there and evaporate out and leave a hard
solidified chunk of salt in the system
and really there's a lot of different
methods a guys swear by some guys will
use salt neutralizers and other products
for cleaning up the tank honestly we
just use water Dawn dish soap or some
type of other cleaner as long as we
flush the system out really well it's
gonna be fine so the first step that
we're going to take is obviously fill
the the tank up with water now we rinse
out the insides of the tank depending on
how the clean or dirty they are it's
just a good practice to have especially
if you're gonna be using the units for
may be watering going into the summer
herbicide applications but basically
what that entails is we just run a
garden hose up inside flush off the
sides of the tank and then we only have
about 300 gallons in this thousand
gallon sprayer that's gonna be plenty to
flush the system out what we're gonna do
now is we're going to go up there we're
throwing a little bit of dawn or
whatever you want to use to clean it out
and then we're just gonna let the search
them the system recirculate for a little
bit so we're gonna have the main tank
valve open and then you'll see the two
inch self oil line on our new models
here is actually how we're just going to
recirculate it around
we're gonna let that run for all good
five minutes just to make sure at the
pump and everything is cleaned out and
then and then from there we will be
pumping it out through the the boom the
valves and everything else so when we
get started on that oh yeah make a
bubble bath one thing to consider this
truck obviously has a hydraulic pump on
it but if you do have the gas pump on
your on your sprayer now it was a really
good time to throw in either a
stabilizer or some kind of fuel
treatment additive I'm a big fan of the
marine stable it's got the ethanol
neutralizers and it had really good luck
with that
just make sure that you put something in
there so if the carb doesn't get plugged
when sitting over the humid months
all right so we've let the tank
recirculate for a couple minutes here
and now the way that we're gonna clean
out our electronic system is by turning
on the controller itself in the truck
and what we're gonna want to do is flip
to manual mode because it knows that
we're not moving
take my hold switch off there and by
going to volume per minute now this is
the exact same method that you would use
if you're in a small parking lot or you
don't want to run an auto and you open
up the servo we're gonna open up our
valve what you can't tell right now it's
my boom sections are actually off and
the truck is off we're gonna open our
servo up wide open and then we're gonna
open up our three boom sections what
that's going to do is obviously flush
that water that we have through the
electronics and and out the boom
it's a good idea to clean up the boom to
four sitting just so that you don't have
any issues coming into the fall when you
want to use it again so we're going to
do that here fire up the truck
this will engage our PTO
and now we'll turn our food sections
and you can see opening up the servo 14
gallons per minute throughout the centre
boom I'm not gonna turn my side we've
done some actually in the shop right now
but you can you can pump it out this way
if you want to speed things up we're
actually just going to we're gonna pump
up through the two inch line here on the
truck itself just because we're inside
it's a good idea I did just flip on my
three lambu that way the control valves
for the boom sections got cleaned out
but in all honesty once we pump it out
like this we'll will be good for the
final steps of the procedure here okay
so we finished pumping out the the
contents of the tank just a few other
steps left here that that we want to
make sure that we recover one is we have
our filter element obviously usually you
don't mess with this a whole lot if
you're getting good flow and everything
your filter is likely fine but the end
of the season we do like to clean that
out again because anything we do now is
gonna be a lot easier when we we get
that unexpected snowfall in in October
so easiest way to do this just like in
the field you can drain your your filter
body so you don't take a bath with it
and also we're gonna pull the plugs on
the pump itself and they're generally
gonna be pretty tight what this is gonna
do it's actually going to drain the pump
we got one more on the bottom here
there we go okay now we got the bottom
plug out and you can see that there's
actually quite a bit of quite a bit of
product left inside there it's actually
pretty important to do because even if
you let your sprayer sit for a long
period of time during the winter what
can happen is actually that water can
evaporate out of the pump we've taken
apart quite a few pumps that we've had
sent back by customers that were
defective and and what you can actually
see is the line where the salt brine or
the was in it and the rest of the pump
is actually all salt and that can
actually be pretty pretty hard on these
seals in there because that salt will
get in between the seals and then you
have a very very abrasive surface when
that pump fire is up again so it's a
pretty simple process to do we'll even
do it during the season if our temps are
gonna fall really cold then we're not
gonna be the icing it might not had
enough additive in the system well drain
all the plumbing on them the exact same
concept as if you were you know draining
plumbing in a house or or a garden hose
so that's about it for this we're gonna
pull this filter off just need a a pipe
wrench to do that and we actually
haven't even changed this filter yet or
you or even checked it so we'll be first
time you see what's actually in it and
you can see we actually have quite a bit
of junk in the air a lot of that is from
not cleaning out the tank when we pop
the bulkheads in it some of the sealing
agent but you can actually see how much
these filters can take we've been
running this I don't know we probably
have you know 5,000 gallons through this
truck and with all that being filtered
out we still didn't have any performance
issues so nice thing about these filters
all you do have to do is wash them out
and then install them the exact same way
that you took them apart so we're gonna
do that and then we'll put all this back
together here now one of the final steps
that I recommend if you do have a
gasoline engine make sure that you clean
everything up really well and then we're
gonna want to focus on putting some
penetrating oil or
fluid film wd-40 something on the engine
just so any residual salt that might be
there isn't going to cause any any
rustling issues with the the humidity
and the oxygen during the during the
summer one part in particular that we
like to focus on is actually at the
recoil cover where the flywheel and the
block meet most of the engine failures
that we see are due to that part seizing
up for some reason that main bearing
there or the the crank bearing must be
very susceptible to getting salt in it
when it sits and then actually will lock
the entire engine up it doesn't hurt to
put a little oil on the cylinder maybe
if you like to fog your engines with
some fogging oil that works really well
too but really at the end of the day
your equipment will take care of you the
way you take care of it so once you do
that to the engine the last step when we
pull it out of the truck is obviously
disconnecting the wiring and that'll
just be our 10 pin connector that we
have that that goes from the cab to the
electronics here and make sure you put
some dielectric grease on that again if
there's any corrosion so you might see
use some electrical terminal cleaner and
get that taken care of dielectric grease
put the caps on usually the wiring
harness is gonna stay with your trucks
so make sure that you wrap that up on
your extension harness and put it in a
safe place if your controller is not
permanently mounted there are two spots
in the or for the wiring that you're
gonna disconnect and that entire
controller can come out of the cab for
you make sure you put them in a safe
place you know you can find them when
when next season comes around again yeah
just washing the the metal and
everything itself maybe if you want to
put a little oil or penetrating oil or a
fluid film again on the skid
touch up any spots it might be chipped
from rust just anything to help increase
the longevity of the unit but that's
pretty much it
really it all this applies to everything
that we have just make sure that you you
flush water through it made a little bit
of soap get all of the the valves and
everything opened up and your unit
should be ready to go for for next
winter